стоп які амбіції починають бавитися в
політичні забави для багатьох вже війна
Десь там далеко і усе мене страшно
трапляє Я думаю що це бісить всіх
громадян нашої держави оці Які себе ні в
чому не зреалізували оці ходять
коментують дивишся там хтось по
телевізору виступає в мене так заплітає
А ти ж відчуваєш що він бреше любить
кусати от за це такі знаєте
легенькі місця приймає всі міжнародні
делегації тобто кіт виконує дуже важливу
місію як змінилися за час
повномасштабної війни відносини з паном
Зеленським слухайте людині міняють
обставини міняються то був нормальний
людину ти лишається нормальним тобто
поганим той знаєте горбатого могила не
знаю виправити
сьогодні спілкуємося з міським головою
Львова Андрій садовим Пане Андрію Вітаю
вас Доброго здоров'я Пане Андрію у
Львові ліквідовані усі парафії
Московського патріархату як вони
нещодавно офіційно заявили як реагуєте
на заяву деяких вірян про те що мовляв
це порушення їхніх правил у вас навіть
називали безбожником Яка ваша реакція на
таке Ну в нас відбулося все з любов'ю
насправді
люди які служать в тих парафіях ви
зрозуміли що змінився час
і в нас не було якихось там бійок там чи
сучок так були деякі словесні перепалки
навіть велике приміщення на Пекарській
нам просто
передали самим під революційний центр бо
я думаю що ми напевно єдине місто в
Україні яке так спокійно вирішило
це важливе питання а все ж таки де-не-де
ось ці думки деяких вірян проскакують що
мовляв це тиск що це порушення їхніх
прав як на це відповідати
ви розумієте що згідно нашого
законодавства церква церква її
відділення від держави тому якщо кожен
працює чесно виконує свої функції тоді
все гаразд якщо би Московський
Патріархат в перші дні війни
публічно оголосив Що вони відлучаються
від Кирила вони засуджують агресію Я
думаю напевно би все по-іншому
вибудовувалося вони цього не зробили
і Вибачте мене це є війна
нас б'ють і Кирил благословляє вбивати
українців Про яку тут може ввести
дискусію це є війна нас вбивають що
зробила Влада Влада прийняла рішення
стосовно реєстрації
громади перереєстрації громад як міський
голова Я взагалі в ці дні був
в Херсоні в Миколаєві
Просто ми заздалегідь вели розмови
спілкувались ми пояснювали який буде
сценарій що є людський Гнів і треба
поважати рішення людей Ну мені здається
що у Львові це якийсь
а в Україні в Україні це складно тому що
дуже багато людей у владі вони
підтримують Московський патріархат і їм
важко визначитись на які вони стороні
єднання церкви в умовах війни все ж таки
сталося повномасштабної війни Як ви
гадаєте якби не цей Фактор відбулось би
це єднання в принципі
коли тебе вбивають то звичайно українці
перед розстрілом об'єднується все що
класики говорили
ієрархії сьогодні займають тверду
проукраїнську позицію але я би дуже
хотів щоб скоро у часі В нас була там
одна християнська церква
тому що коли ти проводиш Раду єпископів
для тебе приходить там нація єпископів
то так воно знайде трошки дивною ну ви
розумієте є речі які важко зупинити але
є моменти коли йде процес пришвидшення
війна вона фокусує свій чужий Свій Чужий
коли війни немає то можна говорити
заговорити дискусії вигідно не вигідно
політика А зараз ні
свої
це наша доросла лікарня бачите це дитяче
оцими перебудували сім поверхів під
реабілітацію це ми вже з вересня
припасовуємо біонічні протези до наших
поранених має свою майстерню моя мета
збудувати потужне виробництво щоб ми
мали сучасне якісне виробництво протезів
сьогодні десь туди до 20 тисяч людей по
певних підрахунках потребують протези в
Україні дивлячись взагалі на всі ці
здобутки як вважаєте яка роль мерів під
час повномасштабної війни і ваша зокрема
кожен мер має
персональну відповідальність і кожне
місто має свою специфіку можна наприклад
є Херсон чи є Миколаїв дуже важко ви
розуміли наприклад Київ мав би бути
лідером в цьому процесі
тому що в них є дуже багато грошей не
мають кошти як гадаєте чому не став
лідером ви знаєте тому що можливо
забагато різних справ і важко зробити
фокус от ми це поставили як фокус тому
що коли кожного дня поранені Ну ти
повинен думати А як завтра буде
відбуватися так
і тому для мене це пріоритет ваша особи
відповідальність ваша місія ви її
виконали Звичайно що ні
місія є це життя прожити життя гідно і
зробити те що важливо сьогодні робити і
думати про завтрашній день тому це
знаєте як ти в океані ти пливеш тільки
коли Закинь закінчився твій Твоя подорож
мов хтось там всевишній скаже виконати
місію Чи ні Які у вас за часів
повномасштабної війни стосунки з іншими
мерами міст Чи якось об'єднуєтеся
політично аби рухати позитивні зміни
вперед зі всіма рівні робочі відносини
якщо врахувати що це той факт що вони
попросили очолити палату громад то треба
на це брати таку трошки огляд згідно
функцію ми мали ще одну форму
в якомусь спав президент виступав
генеральний стартер НАТО і там я
мудрував панель мерів
фактично працював Як ви так задавав
питання було дуже цікаво такий досить
для мене отримати насправді мера є
самодостатньо особистості
Кожен з них теоретично знає що робити Я
би дуже хотів щоб було розуміння
державній владі що міста це є оцей
таємний інгредієнт Який дасть успіх для
країни Тому що тут можна дуже швидко
зареалізувати справу тут Ненсі
бюрократії і наше законодавство потребує
серйозних змін щоб
забрати ті всі перепони штучні наприклад
сьогодні
захист готовий нам помагати дуже часто
міста можуть мати співпрацю з
міжнародними фінансовими інституціями
маючи здавати кращі умови чим держава
Але є різні обмеження дозволи Мінфін
погодження ну це така бюрократія яка
забирає нерви здоров'я
багато інших речей наприклад от місто в
цьому році
віддає до держави 1 млрд 340 мільйонів
це реверсна дота вирівнювання чому я
специфіка є громада самодостатній А є
громади які на себе не заробляють тільки
не заробляють їх треба приєднати до тих
і заробляють І тоді все буде окей щоб ми
ті кошти не віддавали ми їх потрапимо
наприклад на освіту чи навіть само
медицину був би Значно краще результат
Хоча зараз щоб ви розуміли Ми дуже
багато коштів виділяємо на збройні сили
це тільки 500 мільйонів в цьому році ми
живими грошима віддаємо на наші збройні
формування які захищають нашу державу
там на сході на півдні біля бахмута хоча
ж ну це не є функція міста але це наш
обов'язок тому що там є наші львів'яни І
сьогодні ми у Львові там не почали
великих масштабних проектів кожна гривня
йде на забезпечення життєдіяльності на
допомогу збройних сил
ви розуміли я взагалі коли був військо
от я служив авіації Я маю велику повагу
до літаків це є наші українські літаки
які На мою думку ми повинні випускати
великі кількості тому що ми маємо
потенцію А це турецький барректар це
мені подарували його копію це Шептицький
коли головою фундації був Любомир Гузар
Це була моя така перша робота серйозна А
це святий Антоній коли ви щось загубили
треба помолитися до Святого Антонія
молилися коли щось губили та я ну в
родині В нас так
помагає на мене правда син п'ятий
Антоній то вредник конечно
от ви кажете об’єднати громади так чи
була думка про тебе Під крилом можливо
Львівської громади об'єднати довколишні
і західні якісь громади Сьогодні ми
опрацьовуємо
ідею стосовно Львівської агломерації
це має бути об'єднання громад навколо
міста Львова щоби спільного визначати
стратегію нашого розвитку щоб бути
більшим центром залучення інвестицій щоб
спростити всі процедури зараз от
законодавстві так прописано що в тебе
вилучають кошти з бюджету а ті ж
наприклад інвестуєш кошти в будівництво
мереж потім ти надієшся що буде
працювати підприємство бо люди отримують
зарплату і буде там податок по дохідний
тип бюджет міста в тебе його забирають
то є багато таких нюансів які можна
легко виправити і сьогодні це головна
тема
стосовно розмови мерів з урядом хочемо
вірити що уряд це зрозуміє До речі Яка у
вас комунікація з Центральною владою як
вона можливо змінився і характер за час
повномасштабної війни
Як триває Цей діалог якщо брати мене
персонально то достатньо добре
і президент приїжджає до Львова із
прем'єрами спілкування міністр часто
бувають у Львові на сьогодні всі
делегації вони йдуть через Львів тому
Звичайно Це для нас плюс Якщо говорити
про Мері інших міст не завжди є так
добре тому що кожен урядовець сьогодні
перевантажений великий кількості Проблем
не завжди є час йому
зрозуміти важливі спілкування та з мером
невеликої громади як змінилися за час
того масштабної війни відносини з паном
Зеленським як можете це охарактеризувати
Я
маю повагу за честь коли він приїжджає і
там короткий моменти спілкування з ним
не перевтомлюю не перенавантажує
Стараємося всі проблеми вирішувати а от
якщо порівнювати до періоду до Великої
війни І зараз є якась зміна між вами
чисто навіть робоча можливо характер
діалогу Мені здається достатньо
добрий конект
він не змінився слухайте люди не
міняються
обставини міняються люди не міняються
хто був нормальний людину ти лишається
нормально тому поганим той знаєте
горбатого могила не знаю виправити війна
робить тебе старішим дай Бог мудрішим
з'являється більше твердості це
відповідальність
розуміти що сьогодні
ми з вами президент також несе
відповідальність за націю з української
націю за сьогодення і за наступні
покоління Я маю повагу до Зеленського до
людини Я маю повагу до посади президента
тому що це законно обрана людина
особистість а оцінювати президента Можна
тоді колись закінчується
обід Ти можеш говорити яким він був
прийняти з іншими а сьогодні він мені
здається перфектно виконує свою роботу
тому що так як він презентує державу в
світі Я не пригадую щоб Колись так
презентував будь-хто з інших президентів
це феноменальний талант як ви гадаєте
[музика]
загалом робить держава зараз аби ми
вистояли чи доречно будь-яка критика
взагалі влади
дивіться
критика
допускається
критиканство небажане що ти маєш зауваги
і Можна ці зауваги про дебатувати Окей А
коли просто це погано бо це погано тому
що погано а що від цього поміняється
лід можна розтопити тільки теплом Я
завжди стараюся знаходити
конструктивну співпрацю зі всіма Як ви
гадаю тому повномасштабні війни зумовили
можливо появу нової генерації політики
які будуть дійсно рухати Україну вперед
по-новому от ваші спостереження щодо
цього йти
Я взагалі критичний до політиків
нових чи старих тому що в Україні дуже
часто в політику йдуть люди які себе не
могли зреалізувати в чомусь іншому і це
є велика проблема якщо ви сьогодні
повиганяєте з державної служби велику
кількість людей то велика частина з них
не знайде роботу
а тут же ж мають працювати найкращі
от я є щасливий що наприклад в міській
раді Львова працює Дуже багато класних
людей за якими стоять черги щоб їх
переманити на іншу роботу вони там
отримують набагато більше так але в них
є відповідальність тому що вони сьогодні
творять історію і це є важлива річ
Ну ви гадаєте що є ті хто можливо от як
ви кажете Не зреалізувалися і зараз вони
є в нашій політиці чи Зараз таких людей
немає
Я ж це бачу по ситуації вже починають
бавитися в політичні забави для багатьох
вже війна Десь там далеко Ну це є
глупота тому що ми знаходимося в
активній фазі війни і ворог ще не є
знищений ворог має достатньо ресурсу і
сьогодні той хто розчіпляє ситуацію
всередині він працює на інтереси ворога
треба це розуміти кого маєте на увазі чи
я маю на увазі знаєте образ такий
об'єднаний тобто глупого політика який
не розуміє реалії сьогодення
сьогодні Слава Богу працює Верховна Рада
голосує закон на 99% достатньо якісний
один із Закон мене звичайно вивів з
рівноваги Це закон 5-65 які стосуються
містобудування в якому вилучили
можливість міст впливати на взагалі
політику містобудування то це чисто
либідський закон який провуювали за
будівельники які думали під шумок вони
самі тепер хочуть давати дозволи самі
приймати експлуатацію де хочуть будувати
як будувати потім вони зникли і коли
Люди приходять до міста як ти поясниш
людям що в тебе ті повноваження забрали
Слава Богу що Президент цей закон не
підписав станом на сьогодні оце Велика
радість і надія що все-таки що мудрість
переможе і можна буде знаєте Там дійсно
підготувати законодавчі документи Але
вже на площадці конгресу з усіма
обговоривши тобто закони мають сьогодні
об'єднувати людей у 2019 14-му році ви
особисто брали участь в президентських
виборах того разовий зняли кандидатуру
як гадаєте звісно після перемоги У вас
ще будуть амбіції на такий крок які
амбіції про що ви говорите в мене
сьогодні одна амбіція щестю дослужити
оцей період який я сьогодні маю він
уявляєте навантаження які лягають
кожного дня Тобто я не бачу дітей я не
маю часу поспілкуватися з дружиною Мені
соромно перед моєю мамою там друзі мене
бачать хіба що десь там коли я щось
коментую розумієте в мене нема ні суботи
ні не вільні вихідного ви собі уявляєте
через що ми сьогодні проходимо але
хлопцям які на передовій 100 разів важче
і розуміючи це я зціпив зуби Я просто
Пашу зранку до вечора все Оце моя
відповідальність сьогодні Які амбіції це
тільки хор Людина яка не розуміє що це
таке Вона має амбіції кожна адекватна
людина сьогодні служить державі і робить
свою роботу і немає часу
починалося балабольство і там
цвітіння по екранах розумієте А оці Які
себе ні в чому не зреалізували оці
ходять коментують і виступають і оце
мене страшно трапляє Я думаю що це
бісить всіх громадян нашої держави
розумієте людина нас відчуває деколи
дивишся там хтось по телевізору виступає
в мене так заплітає А ти ж відчуваєш що
він бреше Розумієш І це ми з вами
відчуваємо от сьогоднішній політиком
який сьогодні є Так вони повинні
розуміти що вони мають бути хорошим
гумусом на якому виростуть нові дерева і
дуже часто ці хлопці які сьогодні воюють
дівчата Вони мають шанс бути на моєму
політиками тому що сьогодні зовсім інший
склад
війська Я знаю дуже багатьох
інтелектуалів які сьогодні воюють які
розуміють що таке відповідальність і що
таке моментом сьогоднішнього часу
дивіться перемогти у війні це не тільки
видавити ворога з нашої землі це
перебудувати нашу державу економіку А це
надскладний процес тому що це історичний
момент для нас це буде дуже складно
повномасштабна війна досі триває Росія
не припиняє бомбити міста Дніпро Умань
останні новини як ви оцінюєте безпеку
Львова зараз
Я думаю що сьогодні більшість міст мають
достатньо рівно ситуацію
різниця нашої безпеки Львівської
заключається в тому що якщо ракети
летять зі сторони казки то ми маємо 30
хвилин якщо зі сторони там Білорусії там
17 хвилин от і вся різниця в Херсоні
просто артилерійські обстріли там Дніпро
фактично Там йде аляр і зразу
йдуть вибухи там в Нікополі спочатку
вибухи потім малярні тому в цьому плані
Львів має свої плюси але з іншої сторони
в нас інша відповідальність тому що ми
сьогодні є одним з найбільших світових
хабіб для поранених для переселенців
людей які в біді і оце наша
відповідальність дати оцю любов дати
відчуття гідності як місто готується до
наступної зими з можливими блекаутами ми
ще влітку Минулого року запаслися
великою кількістю дров
і в нас ви розуміли 6 тисяч укриттів
півтори тисячі укриттів обладнані
пічками ви знаєте які пічки спрацювали в
складні моменти люди їх використали
навіть Я бачу по багатьох організаціях
установах люди повністю перепланували
своє життя щоб ви розуміли наші медичні
основи комунальні вони сьогодні мають а
першу категорійність наприклад по
електропостачання дизель генерацію
основну потім дизельгенерацію запасну
потім плюс маємо централізоване тепла
маємо альтернативне тепло яке ми
виробляє має четвертопаливні котли у нас
є декілька систем захисту і це все
спрацювало в критичний момент а сьогодні
переосмисливши це все є декілька нових
планів але я про них вам говорити не
буду
раніше найдорожчі ціни на оренду були
завжди оренду житла завжди були в Києві
тепер багато хто називає все ж таки
Львів ви називали що Давно місцевих які
завищують цінних за оренду відверто
мародерами А як можна фактично вплинути
на ситуацію і зробити місто ще більш
комфортним
я вам назву сотні прикладів коли люди
зменшилися
готелі зменшили ціну тобто вплинуло ваша
Ось ця Ремарка проблему марка тут
розуміння людей
тисячі сімей приймали вдома
наших українців безоплатно готували їсти
то що дійсно Там хтось десь ціну завищив
ми всі ті кейси облікували з кожним
заявником переговорили в мене було одне
прохання до заявників Ви можете написати
заяву в поліцію ні чому А чому
розумієте специфіка Львова що
заключається в тому що в нас ну не дуже
дешева оренда помешкання і коли
наприклад хтось приїжджав зі Сходу
України де помешкання вартувало не
дорого то Львівські ціни видавалися дуже
високими
розумієте Хоча я не виключаю того
моменту що були гідні які хотіли цьому
заробити ми всі матеріали скерували
правоохоронні органи була проведена дуже
серйозна профілактична робота Львів і
сміттєва криза були майже тотожними
поняттями з 2018 року будується
сміттєпереробний завод Який врешті
очікують усі буде добудований коли
очікувати фінал цієї історії завод
дійсно будується
виконано є порядка 25% об'єму робіт
будівельної частини до кінця року
плануємо закінчити будівельну частину і
вже з наступного року буде монтування
обладнання це є один з найбільших
заводів в Україні які будуються і це
буде чи не єдиний новий завод
це великий плюс то що ми перейшли і
пережили сміттєво блокаду Коли у нас
політично давили і мені ставили на стіл
документ підпиши що партія цим поміч у
Верховній Раді має перейти в інший
підпорядкування і тоді ми сміттєво
блокаду знімемо ну це страшні речі Коли
я це розказую
колегам з інших країн світу вони собі не
уявляють що таке може бути Ну я через це
пережив перейшов Я забув це все Мене
цікавить завтрашній день не буду
називати політиків які це все мутили ви
їх самі прекрасно всіх знаєте тому моя
амбіція лишається щоби зробити хороший
завод про гуманітарку на початку року
була така досить гучна новина що на
Львівщині СБУ в чергове викрила схему
розкрадання яка ситуація зараз Які
превентивні заходи аби взагалі це
подолати і Не знищувати нашу репутацію
серед західних партнерів Я би дуже хотів
щоб був Реєстр і були реальні порушники
І за то що хтось крав значить дуже часто
з'являється інформаційне повідомлення
яке виконує свою місію а потім нема
результату
ми еко місто отримали підтримку від
багатьох міст з Європи Наприклад ми
фактично все віддали зразу ж Херсон
Миколаїв Харків Одеса все передавали все
що у нас було ми собі фактично нічого і
не лишали бо не мали морального права
хіба якусь частиночку на те щоб помагати
тим людям які тут нас живуть наприклад
150 тисяч наших українців для яких
сьогодні Львів - це рідна хата Як
контролювати тих хто з рід
них садити в тюрму
коли я доконаний факт порушувати
кримінальне провадження і виносити
рішення суду вирок А якщо нема покарання
говорити а превентивні заходи щоб навіть
не думали ну Дивіться Ну я наприклад
якщо би я знав що хтось вкрав я би сам
розірвав на маленькі частинки
правоохоронні органи працюють
достатньо настільки є багато
Я думаю що вони поставили задачу
виконують
тому що в іміджі так
той хто краде гуманітарку це мародер
практично ворог
тому такий штамп Ну він дуже негативний
були правда ситуації коли волонтерів які
реально помагали Коли їм пробували такі
штамптики чіпляти оце абсурд наприклад
Літинський який є захисником української
мови там його звинуватили в тому що десь
він
був дотичним якихось незрозумілих
процесів не знаючи перед ним вибачилася
поліція тобто багато є глупоти чесно вам
скажу різної Ну що коли є біда Мені
здається що українці на такому знаєте
генетичному моменті об'єднуються і
працюють разом
як тут лапки твої заберу любить кусати
от за це такі знаєте
легенькі місця у нього
Звичайно що ви хотіли на 100 раз був
випадок коли була велика Сирена і він
бідні десь втік то ми його добу шукали
Вся Україна його шукала тоді але він
деколи бере знаєте і там принесете тобі
на коліна посидить моркви чи От
наприклад ми мали в п'ятницю робочу
зустріч з колегами з
міжнародна компанія він прийшов і
керівнику цієї компанії сів так на
коліна почав муркати
дуже важливу місію тому що жарти жартами
але
іноземні гості Вони захоплені від
левчика Як ви весь цей рік морально
почуваєтеся як давайте стрес чи
допомагає вам кіт Левчик саме вам
ну ви ж мені в середину не залізете що
там є ви бачите що є назовні
а всередині є не просто і я не знаю як
ми будемо виходити з тої ситуації щоб я
знав що таке працювати мера наскільки
вона мені випаде Я не знаю як моє життя
вибудувалось Ну я там почав працювати
помаранчеву Революція
революція гідності
російська агресія зараз повноцінна війна
ми не постійно стрес я стимулю зараз то
що Звичайно є це навіть це не стрес Я не
знаю яким словом це назвати загалом в
часи повномасштабної Вільний за весь цей
час у вас була думка що допомогло і вам
особисто всім українцям вистояти бо
іноземні партнери давали Нам доціли
кілька тижнів Я думаю що однозначно без
Божої допомоги це неможливо але Бог дає
силу тому хто готові повірити у власні
сили
наші хлопці наші військові вони просто
повірили свої сили що вони можуть ну
українці є по своїй натурі впертими
людьми
друга річ ну відчуття
моментом
таке буває раз 400 років
коли весь світ
повернувся лицем до України Я маю на
увазі демократичний світ і це Шанс стати
незалежної держави більш розумієте наші
сусіди отримали Незалежність Там литовці
естонці поляки
Чехії
слованці
практично це все відбувалося в минулому
столітті Україна тоді на превеликий жаль
не народила свою повноцінну незалежність
Так ми мали республіку українську Але ми
не мали
самостійності у прийнятті рішень і
сьогодні цей момент власне настав в моля
в муках болі в крові народжується наша
незалежність Я думаю що кожен з нас це
розуміє якщо ми цю гідру Не переможемо
то воювати будуть наші діти і внуки
Дякую вам за розмову дякую